hi
my name is ryan and this is an
introduction to assured workloads
in the next few minutes we'll talk about
how you can make sure that the right
controls are in place so you can run
regulated workloads on google cloud
ready let's get started
[Music]
regulatory compliance can be a challenge
for governments and businesses looking
to use the cloud
some workloads or types of data may have
strict compliance requirements
surrounding data residency data access
and personnel access
at the same time you still want to be
able to use the latest most innovative
cloud services
this is where assured workloads comes
into play
assured workloads is a tool that helps
you run secure and compliant workloads
on google cloud
all organizations have to do is choose
the right regulatory framework and
google cloud will put the necessary
cloud controls in place to support your
compliance requirements across the globe
assured workload supports compliance
with platform controls to create
regulated boundaries on public cloud
infrastructure there are several
platform controls you can choose from
including favorite moderate fedramp high
criminal justice information systems u.s
regions and support
impact level 4 hipaa high trust
eu regions and support and eu regions in
support with sovereignty controls
two areas where these platform controls
help organizations meet compliance
requirements our data residency and
personnel data access controls
first there's data residency for at rest
and in use
assured workloads restricts the regions
you can select for your resources based
on which platform control you choose for
example if you select us regions and
support your resources will be
restricted to u.s regions
if a developer at your organization
tries to create a resource that will
store data at rest in a different region
the action will be blocked and logged
second there's personnel data access
controls
these ensure that only google personnel
who are able to satisfy certain physical
location and background check
requirements are able to access customer
data in the course of a support action
for example if you select fedramp high
support access will be limited to google
personnel who are located in the u.s and
have completed enhanced background
checks
beyond data residency and personnel data
access controls assured workloads
provides customers with security best
practices for key management based on
the compliance requirements of the
organization
a key provision of many regulations is
that organizations need to manage their
own encryption keys
for compliance regimes like il4 assured
workloads mandates customer managed
encryption keys
a key management project is created and
is separated from resource folders to
establish separation of duties between
security administrators and developers
assured workloads also creates a key
ring to store your keys
strong encryption key management and
separation of duties all support
positive security and compliance
outcomes on google cloud for other
compliance regimes customers are able to
receive google manage encryption keys
which by default are fips 142 compliant
assured workloads also supports cloud
kms customer managed encryption keys
cloud external key manager and key
import
assured workloads can also help with
data sovereignty using assured workloads
for eu regions and support with
sovereignty controls
this means that customers in europe have
mechanisms to exercise independent
control over the cloud provider's access
to their data approving access only for
specific provider behaviors deemed
appropriate and necessary by the
customer providing protections against
legal seizure
getting started is easy you can create a
new assured workloads folder by visiting
the google cloud console selecting a
google cloud organization and going to
the compliance section
you will fill out a brief onboarding
stepper selecting options for geographic
jurisdiction compliance type region
folder configuration and key management
fedrate moderate is offered at no
additional cost to customers so you can
begin using it today
in future videos we'll take a closer
look at how to get started
let's take a look at an example use case
a large technology provider to the us
government needed to respond to a
large-scale geopolitical incident which
created new requirements for compliance
the customer was able to expand their
regulatory boundary on google cloud to
meet new compliance and data residency
requirements while still restricting
personnel access controls to us persons
and maintaining their nist 853
and nist 800 171 security controls on
google cloud
after the incident was resolved the
customer was able to rapidly resort to
their regulatory boundary
assured workloads makes adapting to new
compliance requirements easy allowing
the customer to quickly set up or expand
a regulated boundary to maintain
compliance while still being able to use
google cloud's latest innovative
technologies in any of our regions
sometimes an organization will need more
than just one compliance regime for
their cloud resources
let's take a look at an example of a
multinational business that operates in
europe the united states and canada
a top-level folder is created and
registered under which all regulated
workloads live
within the top level folder are
subfolders created by the assured
workloads api for different compliance
regimes that the business needs
in this case there are compliance
regimes for eu regions and support
dod impact level 4 and can regions and
support
within each sub-boulder are the projects
that are subjected to each compliance
regime
all cloud resources within these folders
follow the specific controls and guard
rails to support compliance
so there you have it an overview of what
assured workloads is and how it can help
you more easily run secure and compliant
workloads on google cloud
if you want to learn more visit
cloud.google.com
slash assured workloads
and stay tuned for more episodes of
assured workloads 101 where we'll walk
through how to use assured workloads us
and eu compliance and how to build with
compliance in mind
thanks for watching
[Music]
you